événement de la semaine dans un tout
autre domaine le salon international du
prêt-à-porter féminin qui s'est terminée
mercredi dernier après avoir vu défiler
non seulement une escouade de bien jolis
mannequins mais également près de
cinquante mille acheteurs 94 collection
était présente et il n'était pas dénué
d'intérêt puisque 650 journalistes
étaient présents
faut avouer que l'une d'entre elles en
particulier avait de quoi éveiller chez
les plus blasés un regard de lyrisme
vous allez tout de suite comprendre
pourquoi
voici les modèles t-il saint laurent je
mets donc un carré blanc un rectangle
blanc et je laisse parler l'image et
france roshi yves saint laurent a fait
pour 1200 acheteurs des cinq continents
sa petite révolution annuel une
collection pour dames bien chauffé et
pour messieurs inflammable l'isna et qui
rate vêtus de probité candide de
mousseline noire vous les lustres en
cours en flou et en transparent
voyez ne gêne pas du tout pour marcher
hier de velours nouer le ruban
art show biz et ses robes sont faites
pour porter pendant les longues soirées
d'hiver
la chaleur ont bien déclenchée par l de
pas suffire à dégeler l'atmosphère
d'ailleurs avec sejna o'meara mode
relief
et il faudra quatre pierres pour ne pas
prendre feu les cieux en voyant ses
statuts ou les feuilles de vigne sont
remplacés par quelques poils doré
les tailles obligatoire des bas noirs
c'est tellement tally
ce